So, it was great to hear from a real user and to hear her describe her
attributes, use cases, and see how that really
played into the feature that she loved the most.
>> Yeah and let's look at dorm room
Debbie again. We have her attributes and use cases
here. What features do you think she would like,
in her perfect pizza ordering application? Do you think
she would like to split the bill? Do
you think she'd like delivery? Or pick-up? Would she
be into coupons? Or would she want to know
the name of the farmer that made the dough?
[LAUGH]. Or would she want multiple payment
options? Or perhaps hi-res photos of the ingredients?
>> So check all that apply that would make the perfect feature list for Debbie.